piero vignozzi nuova challenge
alcune sono già e consip e pratica o un
preparato tutte queste uova di fatto
quindi la flight solo per il fatto che
le ha preparate sul tema socialmente un
sacco di tempo
dentro c'è la sorpresa ma la sorpresa
cos'è non è una normale sorpresa ma sono
ingredienti slime alcuni sono
ingredienti fantastici alcuni sono
ingredienti terribili tre fortunati
dobbiamo cercare di non scegliere l'uovo
di pasqua con ingredienti slime
sbagliato a movimenti si sia uno slam
schifoso e come sempre alla fine del
video dovrete votare nel sondaggio che
metterò qua se ho vinto io unità che
esistono tutte le s
si è tornato a bottiglia quando io
volevo dire che sia sentito rumore di
sottofondo e berlino che sta giocando
questi giochini preferite esposta come
un pazzo di che gioca se vedete che la
camera si muovo all'inter visto che c'è
qualche cosa perché lui sta inseguendo
si è questo che fa casino di pasqua
bendati a mettere l'ingrediente
nell'ambra colla che abbiamo fatto
mettetevi comodi prendete le patatine
pop corn evitiamo di inizia canevari
sasso che appare disastri bello e vitale
mischierà ci sono esplosivi devo stare
attento come cover del nuovo
berlino è finito di fare che sia perché
io ho fatto volesse di questo la tetta
che cosa cela dentro mi è preso un po un
ovetto mini blu con fiocco viola che
carino allora prima vai a pescarlo anche
tu e perché dovremmo insieme scopriamo
cosa c'è gente che esce sempre berlino
che fa il sottofondo le note lino
attivato di jong ok fatto pecca ai quali
[Musica]
è stato una grande rosa
vediamo subito più facile che a breve lo
trovo in passato si aprisse
vediamo un po oggi a berlino e da lì
capri voglio prima vedere cosa e se c'è
un bicchiere
se un colorante che cosa te e mi va in
barca sociale per mano di bianco fa
prigione
io non si spese fosse il terzo
tutt'altro che ho fatto qualcosa di
perdere glitter verdi
[Musica]
andiamo subito altri nostri primi
ingredienti ecco qua i place verdi
andiamo versarli dentro
oddio poi penso che in questo flime con
la colla bianca scompariranno vediamo ma
per non male carini stanno facendo una
consistenza un po vomitino
senza meravigliosa direi che ci sto
pensando di mettere tanto nero così e
magari esce grigio scuro volevo metterlo
almeno dieci gocce 10 per farlo super
nero
vediamo così che in nero perché ancora
si deve amalgamare bene che un po
marroncino sembra anche rosso ciliegia
così ciliegie dai bagarini del prossimo
uovo di capiterà ma che pare brutto
sfortunato quando vediamo chi li aiuta
primo set ha presentato e degli evviva
vai vizia berlino poi fermo che allora
prendo questo mi sembra molto grande e
questo per ma anche tanto coeli mentre
in vetta celeste con tutto viola che
come indovina si becca mai a brontolare
è rosa a due rose contro queste grandi
fatti vediamo cosa si tratti ma io
questa cosa perché premia per tutto
vediamo vediamo
[Musica]
ecco la sorpresa finora piano piano
oddio meno voleva per davvero una
sorpresa esplosiva di verde altre volte
pecchiamo l'opera basta su tre volte è
più fortunato che si avverte quad ed è
riesploso tutto qui è fantastico sono
stata più fortunata finora per chiamate
a berlino ma finché rischio di una
polvere color oro atti a presente in 26
arup e compagni possono vedere da vicino
ma che hai fatto presente come sono
stato fortunato io la mia sera
e poi anni da cristo verde ovviamente
fin qui tra mostre tantino e perciò il
bordeaux è tantissimo quindi anche se vi
capita molto il colore sarà impossibile
era tutto verde è tornata e tornata la
maledizione è tornata secondo me non
sarei mai andata la maledizione del
verde ma io pensavo che è cambiato casa
se mi sarebbe andata invece no
c'è sempre stata e sempre ci sarà forse
eccolo qua c'è più verde che cosa bella
mi diventa con il film 22 rodio treno
tra studiatissimi era proprio uno degli
uova più fortunati
era quello che ci voleva premio slia un
po tutto dorato
[Musica]
vanta superato antonio mari anche tu
dire tutto la rata lascia un po a
desiderare un punto tratto un grigio gol
[Risate]
in particolare esagitato come averlo
città giocatore capitano casa ragazza
note kakà è un piccolo bambino
le piante e tombole nelle fase sei è un
nobel
ok blu grande fetta farebbe fff
benessere al bellessere appena ho fatto
scelga questa molto bene che ti fa
l'ultimo giorno a presentare sempre
paziente forse prestigio del cibo no non
mi guarda
apriamo un nuovo rosso e sembra
invisibile questo campo la storia un
punto che puzza perché ragione come
contenitore giallo dorato e cosa ma ci
sta benissimo perché per la quantità di
giusta per farlo diventare all'ascolto
quindi non può migliorare in ogni caso
ebbe pregiudizi diamo il pallino ma
forse ci sono falli nei brutti da
qualcosa che si può stare bene e tanto
il verde colore arancio quel e verde
se mi capitava l'arancione sarebbe
diventata un banale abbiamo un po come
diventa questo giallo marroncino con
arancione che bello che vediamo teresse
a migliorarlo le sabbie mobili sembra
gira forza sia sta diventando arancione
e faccio fortunato regione non lo so mi
sembra un colore e un atto un colore
veramente veramente brutto aspettiamo
tre migliori dopo una zuppa di gioco di
carota mi sono capitate le palline blu
almeno qualcosa di carino
vediamo vediamo se diventeranno davvero
cosa diventerà tutto verde accendono non
vogliono andare nel perdere anche le
famiglie almeno diventa un po crunch
[Musica]
ovviamente fanno diventato tutte bene
incorporando del verde ma almeno
paradiso ogni crunchy norme lombardo
grande è un nuovo piccolo vediamolo
pregi dottoressa fare sesso
certo questa buffa vi pare poco da
rischiare quali non mi sta guardando
strada cosa mai chiesta disagio venga
bayern ho mischiato questo o per quello
piccolo in mano
nel frattempo se tutta sporca di di un
pigmento questo piccolo grande
abbiamo prima qui pianeti e lode ma più
tantissimi clijsters i tanti colori e
bello vedere gli stellini entrare mi
faccio un sedere vediamo gli aiuti
stanno bene col verde the seas bicolore
[Musica]
apri piano
un po di rosa ne abbiamo visto ma se
migliorerà ancora
speriamo fortunato lite con le stelline
[Musica]
sembra polvere di fata polvere di
unicorno sono tanti colori dorato ruote
questi sono le stelline dentro spero
solo che il verde non risucchierà tutto
benissimo tanto che sarà inutile c'era
tutta l'erba verde ritocchi e te
prepararla forse una volta attivato si
vedrà un pochettino un pochettino si
vedono poco poco bisogna vedere una
volta attivato dovrebbero vedersi meglio
ora vediamo un po acquistato proprio
fortunati in questa zona proprio
convinto del colore che non vediamo
adesso che cercano
così la bello morbido pelo morbido
smettiamola schiuma che bello loro
bisogni per far sì che il rumeno
macchiato da zucchero filato mischiare
[Musica]
profumo è buono ma marrone e la cosa mi
sembrano non abbiamo avuto molto effetto
marrone cioccolato lavaggio e ora
andiamo dal t bar
noi facciamo vedere dovrete votare per
il migliore per spetta paghetta mera
siete pronti tre ex live pensavo molto
peggio è il sito molto femmine uscito un
bardo pisello molto chiaro e si vedono
le palline
guardate che carine e si vedono anche un
pò i glitter ora sentiamo i suoni
[Musica]
quindi questo è il mio swing
vediamo ora quella di vitale in avanti
che in uscita per flachi che bello il
colore è una sorta di arancio rischiesto
sembra una canzone pastello quasi mi
piace molto la consistenza mi piace
molto di questo slime perché siamo i
suoni bel po king stiamo adesso anche le
bollicine non ci sono o non sono tante
sono poche però intanto veri non è
abbastanza allungabile bello bello
vediamo dove ogni dubbio
io guardo lo stesso colore giusto che il
camionista servizio e vitale lasciato
challenge e ora clicca su una di queste
quattro cartellini per vedere i nostri
altri video su quella che preferite
bonini indiani ciao